hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 japanese science fiction movie
called the door into summer
the movie begins with a young man named
soichiro to kakura who just lost both of
his parents
so ichiro never felt lonely as he found
a friend named pete
soon later both of them were taken in by
his father's friend named koichi who
also has a daughter named rico
matsushita
learns mechanical engineering from
koichi
unfortunately both of his parents then
pass away because of a plane crash rico
is then taken by her uncle kazuto in
march 1 1995 suichiro just invented
artificial general intelligence robots
called a1 and it's being developed by
his uncle's company future works
enterprise or short as fwe
at the same time the snow starts to fall
and pete asks suichiro to open all the
doors in the house as he looks for
summer to come meanwhile rico visits and
do houseworks for him but unfortunately
she will move away from the city soon
meaning that she won't be able to visit
her brother often
because a1 is a success he is starting
his late father's project the project is
a plasma battery to which machines won't
have to be recharged anymore
suddenly his girlfriend and also
kazuto's assistant named rinchiro ishii
also visits him to give him some
documents to sign
however rico seems unhappy with
shiroishi then leaves
the document contains fwe stock
assignment from soichiro himself to
shiraishi
even though it is mostly a decision from
kazuto soichiro agrees and signs the
documents without hesitation
shura ishi then kisses him feeling
grateful a week later soichiro urgently
comes to the main office where he meets
kazuto
kazuto then suddenly starts a special
shareholders meeting he wants to release
all of a1 projects to manix enterprises
and stop all of the current development
for a1
so each euro refuses saying that a1
isn't ready yet
suddenly shiraishi suggests that they
vote for the proposal and she votes for
the proposal to be executed the results
is final and it turns out soichiro has
been set up by them his connection to
the company is terminated and he is also
forbidden to use all of the company's
facilities and equipment
he rushes back to his house just to find
that all of the equipment has been taken
away by the company not long after rico
comes to visit soichiro again only to
find that he is in a state of despair
because he lost everything again
rico then suggests herself to stay and
helps her brother but suichiro already
gives up and says that she's just a kid
and can't help him in any way
rico then leaves him
at the same time he finds a cradeos cold
sleep brochure a company which can let a
person sleep for five to thirty years he
brings pete and immediately goes to the
place
there he decides to take the program for
him and pete
he also assigns his shares from fwe to
rico
after the examination the doctor finds
that his blood alcohol is over the limit
and rejects his proposal to get the
program
the doctor then schedules the
re-examination for the next day and
tells him to rethink his decision
later that night suichiro flashbacks to
his happy moment spent with rico
because of that he thinks giving up is
not the way and he decides to confront
shiroishi and kazuto once again
meanwhile rico arrives at kazuto's house
she overhears that kazuto and shiroishi
plan to complete the a1 and plasma
battery with other engineers
rico immediately goes upstairs and calls
shoachiro but it directs to voicemail
kazuto approaches rico but she says it
was her friend and runs to shuchiro's
house
kazuto checks the last call and realizes
it was not rico's friend and runs to get
rico
meanwhile shura ishii receives a call
from shochiro asking for her location
arriving there each euro states that he
will see a lawyer to disclose everything
to ruin the company's reputation
shura ishii eventually yielded but
suddenly she drugs suichiro
she takes suichiro's bag and pete comes
to his aid and creates a mess in the
room
suddenly a window breaks which pete runs
to the direction and a pickup truck
drives away from the house
while asking soichiro about the truck
she spots soichiro's cold sleep program
and it gives her an idea
sometimes later soichiro gains
consciousness but now he is inside the
cryo sleep pod owned by manix
enterprises as she explains how she
managed to get the program the cryosleep
pod starts to activate and soichiro is
forced to sleep
so ichiro wakes up 30 years later where
he's very puzzled and meets the doctor
that looks like the doctor he met from
30 years ago
turns out the current doctor is not the
same person as the doctor from 30 years
ago as his father
so each hero immediately looks for pete
the cat but the one who comes is pete a
humanoid robot that is assigned to take
care of him
pete brings him to his room where he'll
be staying for five days
since pete is a robot so each hero
assumes that the robot will execute his
commands
he commands pete to tell the person in
charge that he wants to leave right now
pete then leaves but says such a pain
which surprises surituro at night
soichiro is informed that there are no
assets to his name as manix went
bankrupt
he is also given rico's address as rico
repeatedly calls the company to inquire
about his awakening the next day suicide
runs away from the hospital bringing his
cassette player and wallet with him
he goes to the taxi stand but can't find
any taxi there pete suddenly comes and
tells him that people must use an app to
call a taxi
so each euro is very confused as there's
no driver as the taxi is now fully
automatic
soichiro commands pete to get out but he
refuses saying that he has just escaped
and he is defective
pete threw his wallet because in the
current era all transactions use mobile
feed also says that he follows suichiro
because he understands that suichiro is
the one who designed the robot
they arrive at the address given where
they find the room is so dirty and messy
turns out it's shiroishi who gives the
address
she tells him that kazuto died one year
after his cryosleep and she spent time
in prison because there's a mysterious
man exposing her for evading taxes
she also tells suichiro that the night
when he was drugged his house burned and
rico was nowhere to be found so ichiro
then assumes rico is dead and mourns at
her grave after that suichiro remembers
how pete the cat always looks for the
door into summer even though snow just
started to fall then he is motivated to
look for the door which means the
mysterious man that shiraishi mentioned
enrico's death
with pete's help they eventually find
out that fwe was acquired by guardian
manufacturing
suddenly pete gets ready to activate
sleep mode and explains that sleep mode
is where a robot goes into a state of
self-regenerative mode
so each hero then asks pete to show the
battery which he does and turns out the
source of energy is from the plasma
battery pete is a product from aladdin
industry one of the dominating humanoid
robot markets
the next day they go to visit the
guardian company
there pete tries to ask one of the
female robots out but gets rejected so
each hero also gets rejected to see the
president but suddenly the robot allows
them to see the president the president
gota is very glad to see suichiro and
seems like he knows suichiro from long
ago as he shows suichiro the book signed
by himself
gota also says that suichiro gives him
an exclusive about the plasma battery
after that gota tells him that he went
to meet professor toy and signed the
book for him at the same place a long
time ago
they then see a news recording about
professor toy embezzling money to fund
his research that is called time
transfer machine
despite all that so each euro is puzzled
and can't remember anything he then
assumes that there is someone using his
identity to complete the plasma battery
they go back to goda where he finds the
stock was assigned to satotaro one of
the founders of aladdin
pete also finds the one who invented the
first robot model was suichiro himself
and the patent attorney was satotaro
then he finds the second model inventor
was rico sato
from all the things they found soichiro
connects everything and finally realizes
something
the following day they visit professor
toy who is also very glad to see him
he asked soichiro to get back to 30
years ago as he already completed the
time transfer machine perfectly
turns out the mastermind behind all of
the events is suicidal himself professor
toy also gives them gold to fund his
research for his past self
so each hero then gives farewell to pete
the machine starts to activate but then
pete rushes to him and they are
transferred to the past
so each euro wakes up a day before a1
finishes and meets a man who introduces
himself as satotaro
taro cashed out the gold soichiro
brought back from the future and already
knows everything as pete told him
everything
taro lives with his wife named midori at
night they plan everything that must be
done and after that so each euro starts
to work on the plasma battery blueprint
the next day he immediately goes to
visit professor toy in a restaurant
he gives all the money to professor toy
who rejects it but eventually accepts
the money after explanation from
soichiro
after that the shop owner's son who
turns out to be gota watches soichiro on
the news as an inventor and asks for his
hand sign
later that night taro tells suichiro
that midori got into an accident a few
years ago then lost her ability to use
her legs
after that so each euro asks for taro's
service again that is to expose
shuroishi for tax evasion to take down
manix enterprises then all the stock
shares will be given to taro as he will
become the president of the new company
which he later named aladdin
so each euro also asks a favor to let
rico stay with them
time passes then the day where soichiro
got tricked by the company comes
pete rushes to stop the truck that
contains soichiro's equipment he gets
hit by the truck but it doesn't stop him
shocked in fear the driver runs away
from the scene
meanwhile soichiro finishes the
blueprint and then rushes to kazuto's
house
he cracks the window and takes pete the
cat away with him
he takes peed in rushes to meet rico who
is looking for him after overhearing
kazuto's conversation
at the same time pete arrives and he
burns his house where he spent most of
his time
they then drive to taro's house and so
each hero introduces rico to sato's
family after that he says goodbye to his
beloved sister and also to pete who also
will be waiting for his return
the next day the future soichiro takes
pete the cat and goes to cradles to take
the cold sleep program
since then rico studies hard and also
becomes an inventor ten years after that
she also takes a cold sleep program
thirty years later suichiro wakes up and
meets again with pete and pete the cat
in the end of the movie suichiro is
informed about rico's condition who also
just wakes up from cryosleep in the end
of the movie suarchiro rushes to meet
rico and they once again reunite
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching